we begin with this developing story the
driver charged with killing five
bicyclists near searchlight last month
will stay behind bars for now without
bail jordan barson had his first court
appearance earlier this morning
following his extradition from arizona
our hector mejia has the latest for us
on this case jordan barson learned about
the charges filed against him directly
from a judge his two previously
scheduled court hearings were delayed
because he was in quarantine the 45 year
old has been charged with 14
felony counts including dui resulting in
death
and reckless driving barson is accused
of killing
five bicyclists on december 10th on u.s
95 near searchlight
the group was riding from las vegas to
nipton according to investigators
methamphetamine was found in his system
barson's defense argued for bail to be
set at 20
000 judge susan bockham said no way
she said barson is not only a danger to
the community but a flight risk as well
she pointed out that if he is found
guilty he faces over a hundred years in
prison
if he's given the maximum sentence i
don't think that there's any amount of
money
that can satisfy the safety of the
community after the
horrendous decision that we've set you
know we see that he may
drive nine times over the legal limit
the i-team learned that barson is now
declared an imminent hazard to public
safety
federal investigators say barson and
roadrunner transport az
the company he worked for were not
carrying a log book as required by law
records also show the company is not
authorized to work as an interstate
carrier
barsonsneck's court hearing is scheduled
for january the 21st
reporting outside the regional justice
center hector mejia
8 news now